no this is a fun way to make an
impression on someone hello
um guess who in the room just got off a
plane from Austin Texas and has a shower
did today not that girl does girl okay
so my voice is crazy because I just got
back from roosterteeth convention which
is this gamer crazy awesome wonderful
come on Jenna shooting this video my
iPhone here's the thing there are things
happening there's a reason this is
happening right now to all of us um I
for so long okay this channel hey well
guys look at this channel that I've had
this my very first youtube channel that
I have had and there's all the old
videos on here from when I was in
college and with doing stuff with
Michelle before we had our grace
Michelle channel so I was like I saw
this channel and there's a bunch of male
vlogs on it there's still mail I have to
open make another male blog but I
thought isn't I got an iPhone again cuz
I love it so much everything my teeth
know um I was gonna try and make some
like maybe but maybe daily don't want to
promise that videos for you guys on the
go sometimes like I feel like things
need to be more dynamic so I'm just
gonna do this a little bit you know cuz
then you'll get motion sickness Oh Moses
my foot hurts
ah what was this thing oh so I might be
making these like little videos every
now and then for you guys well you think
of that as a thing happening in our
lives is that too much am i play a
little pressure on your eyes is it too
much it's too much me probably right
yeah I get it it may not happen all the
time maybe sometimes um so I just got
back from roosterteeth convention in
Austin Texas fun crazy fun time um I was
on the women of YouTube panel with
Hannah Hart my dear kitchen Justine I
just seen and Malana is TV from my life
prude girls and it was a wonderful
wonderful panel where any of you there I
had a wonderful time with Mingus dynamic
in well everything
stop um I had a very very excellent time
and then I came back from that today and
I'm tired as [ __ ] my voice has gone like
all good conventions I lose my voice
I've gotten very good at maybe this is a
bad thing to be good that I'm very good
now being on a plane hungover really
good at like we're pressing all the the
swirls of a panic attack that happened
so I think I've mastered that in a way
um so I'm gonna go actually make it
Daily Grace video maybe upload this
maybe I won't even upload this maybe
this has just been me talking to myself
for absolutely no reason no I
okay oh well I probably will yeah I'm
gonna try it or test it and see and then
maybe these will happen from time to
time sometimes I guess so I'm so
non-committal what personality trait
haha so uh I'll see you guys later maybe
shave my legs uh I needed just hygiene
myself for a second by all Texas